it's something that I don't usually talk
about because I'm afraid that I'm making
people uncomfortable it's something that
affects me in almost every aspect of
life there's something about having dark
skin on a woman's body that shapes the
way she moves through the world there's
something about having darker skin on a
male body that shapes the way in which
he moves through the world it has
real-life stakes from what I've seen
growing up dark skin equates to being
poor dirty ratchet they tend to be the
bad guys in Tyler Perry movies straight
from the border that doesn't even make
any sense
I'm Matt deemed as beautiful therefore I
am NOT beautiful and those two are not
really mutually exclusive could it be
that something as early as colonisation
or slavery is primarily responsible for
our beauty standards today we're talking
about who works in the field and who
works in the house we're also talking
about rape the rape of slaves to produce
people who are known as mulatos or
mixed-race these standards of beauty
travel Eurocentric standards of beauty
travel in the dominican society and our
culture they all have a phrase that's
like Miranda la Gazza advancing the
Dominican population and making sure
we're going into how they say the better
if you're lighter you're bettering the
race and you're bettering the island
versus if we're just being you I would
get called the blackness a1 joke that
really stuck with me was like Oh Edgar
so black that when he leaves a car the
check engine light turns on that was a
reference to my skin being as dark as
oil
I felt ugly being
of a darker skin tone so I tried to gel
my hair or I started listening to skater
punk music so I tried culturally to
lighten myself if that makes sense
I went on a trip to Korea with my mom
some woman walked up to my mom and she
asked why is your daughter so dark and
in Korea you have to be pale and I
almost felt like a foreigner and not so
much Korean anymore when we turn off the
lights they say Oh Salam where did you
go
or oh you're really pretty for a
dark-skinned girl are you saying that my
race and just the fact that I am black
is that not attractive in general I
remembered one time that I wanted to be
an angel
in a parade at that time they were like
our races you know they didn't like
black people to be angels and my mommy
got kind of freaked out she was going
like peace to you cannot be an angel
because they couldn't laugh at you I
said but mommy I am an angel and finally
I was an angel and I was the only black
angel walking industry.i my mommy was so
proud about it and I was proud too my
mom started buying me a cream called
fair and lovely I was in third grade
when I started using bleaching creams
and the whole general idea was if I'm
lighter I'll have a better life I'll
have I'll find somebody that's gonna
love me there would still be light and
dark patches on my body and my face
as painful don't hurt and I started
working out in like bad rashes and no
one said anything I had to stop it
myself
how do we fix this we think critically
about colorism we think about where it
began and where it begins and ends with
us I think change starts with providing
more diversity you know providing more
examples of people that look like you if
you look at telenovela z-- they usually
cast the dark-skinned person as the
villain and if you never met a Latino
before you're gonna somewhat think that
so in Japanese media I honestly don't
think I've ever seen a darker skin
female I feel it would be nice to see a
change it needs to start within our own
culture where we can't have Will Smith
filling in every slot for black people
giving dark-skinned people roles that
are not only supporting roles but
leading roles I mean a legit badass
double-oh-seven Latino James Bond that'd
be pretty dope I'm just saying if I
could give a message to someone like me
who's kind of looking at himself and
feeling insecure just know baby you
beautiful believe in yourself just be
you you are perfect just the way you are
that's something that no one has ever
told me and your skin color is a gift
it's never been a blemish or a problem
when you grow up and you look in the
mirror and you're proud of who you are
it will make sense and all the other
voices will go away
and all that's going to be left is you